new this morning there's a new resource
for budding entrepreneurs here in the
valley Candice Charles joining us live
from the College of Southern Nevada and
North Las Vegas with its new center to
help turn ideas into action Candace good
morning
yes we're making dreams into realities
and I love to say a good morning to you
good morning folks website development
accounting funding most importantly can
make or break a new business well that's
where CSN is stepping in with a new
entrepreneurship center now Nevada grow
and CSN receive funding for
entrepreneurship Network Blackstone
lunch pad in 2021 to help get the center
started Nevada grow is geared at helping
establish small businesses with funding
mentoring and resources while Blackstone
launch pad is here for the students Envy
girls already helped more than 847
businesses and student entrepreneurs
here at CSN just won 20
000 video Berkeley and UNLV by facing
first place and Blackstone lunch pads
pitch competition now both students and
small business owners can come to the
center to network and join in seminars
and workshops about everything from how
to do your taxes and media trading
helping Nevada businesses get a strong
foothold on creating a successful
business
that helped our business tremendously
acquire inventory advertising dollars
create more payroll space there's a lot
of resources here that people can tap
into whether it's for finance or whether
it's for just general guidance
yeah the natural center is open to
everyone but to be a part of Envy grow
you must be an established small
business and to join Blackstone launch
pad you must be a student entrepreneur
at CSN now the CSN entrepreneurial
center plans to have a ribbon cutting
ceremony in the fall of course we'll
keep you up to date with those details
and to learn a little bit more about
those qualifications for both of those
programs we'll have those details on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live from
CSN North Las Vegas campus off of
Cheyenne I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now